Thanks very much for having me, Mark.
So before coming to Georgia Tech,
I was at a place called the Regenstrief Institute which,
amongst informatics folks, is a pretty well-known place.
It's the home of one of the earliest physician order entry systems called Gopher.
Also the home base for LOINC which is well-known as well as OpenMRS,
a global open source medical records system.
Regenstrief Institute was a place
where I spent eight years focusing primarily on clinical decision support,
a lot of work about how we can design alerts that are more effective,
how we can create more influential designs
for driving behaviors and decision making amongst physicians.
Regenstrief Institute also is a place that has been a hub for
many years for I'm thinking broadly about the future of informatics,
and my time there was fantastic.
I was very excited to have a chance to come down to Georgia Tech
and take some of the work that we've done in the academic medical centers and
bring it to a technology-oriented institution like Georgia Tech.
Sure, so OHDSI is originally, let me start over there,
so OHDSI actually originally formed as something called OMOP back in 2008.
And that stands for the observational medical outcomes partnership.
OMOP itself was funded by the foundations
of the NIH which was kind of a collective of life sciences,
pharmaceutical companies that came together to say,
how can we understand observational health data
better and look at the research methods, in part,
to get ahead of what was called Mini-sentinel then Sentinel that was part of
an FDA initiative to use observational data to track drug safety.
The OMOP program was very successful in putting together a model of
clinical data, and it grew over a period of five years to
look at pharmacovigilance or drug safety in some very novel ways.
But at the end of the five year funding period,
the lead scientists said, we want to keep going and we want to answer
questions related to comparative effectiveness, related to data quality,
related to value-based care and other areas in healthcare research.
And so they banded together and converted OMOP into something called OHDSI,
which now has expanded to, as you mentioned,
a much larger set with data in the OMOP common data model on over 660 million patients.
There's participants in OHDSI from over 20 countries, So it's become quite large.
So converting data from a source system whatever it may be,
whether it's a Medicare claims document,
whether it's from an electronic medical records system into the OMOP common data model,
which is the standard, is a process we call ETL: Extract, Transform and Load.
And that's certainly used in other areas in addition to health care.
The reason it can be challenging is you have to really understand your data.
You have to understand the source data and
where different types of information are maintained.
You also have to understand the target common data model,
document and the format of how that works.
The most important thing around doing ETL or a transform
into the OMOP CDM is to have people understand the local data environment.
How it gets in there and, basically,
going through the process of mapping up codes can take some time.
The investment, though, is very worthwhile because once you've done it,
there's a lot of off the shelf capabilities that working at OMOP and OHDSI
brings you that are derived from the work of
people literally across the world using that same data model.
One of the other great things about
OMOP as a common data model in the OHDSI network is that
a researcher in California at Stanford can write code that will run on data in Japan,
in Australia, in the UK,
all with a common code base.
So it allows people to ask a question in
their local home environment and actually get results coming in from all over the world.
I think there's very few other ways that you can do something on
that scale globally than with OHDSI and OMOP.
I would agree with that.
I think there are so many nuances that have been, in fact,
proven out in many of the OHDSI research studies where we
look at the same question in different environments,
inpatient and outpatient environments,
EMR-based environments, claims-based data environments and,
indeed, there is a huge amount of
variation that's based on local factors that need to be brought into account.
And it's not that you want to hide those but you want to understand,
you want to recognize and you want to account for them where you can.
So I would agree very much.
A federated model allows that individual local nuance to be brought
to it and it's probably the most effective way to go about doing observational research.
Sure. We've just completed one study looking at a question that the FDA put
out on their website late last year
where they were looking at the question of the safety of a particular medication.
But it's a very rare adverse event they were curious about,
which something called angioedema.
You don't see it very much so if you want to study the risk of angioedema,
you're going to need millions and millions of patients to get at that question.
So with OHDSI, with a network that large,
you can actually ask a question of that across tens of millions,
even hundreds of millions of patients and be
able to generate information which, in this case,
we did and it'll be coming out in a journal currently in
press that did not show effect of that medication and the risk of angioedema.
Another great example of where we would use OHDSI in a research study is for looking at,
for example, the patterns of treatment across hundreds of millions of patients.
How are people being treated for hypertension?
How are people being treated for diabetes?
It may seem very intuitive that there's recommendations out for
the best process or pathway for treating hypertension.
But when you look at what's happening out in the real world it's very different.
So using the OHDSI framework allows you to look at these very large questions.
On a smaller scale, doing predictive models for individual patients,
the best way to generate an accurate predictive model for an individual patient is
to start with tens of millions of patients to begin with and hone in on.
So, generating predictive models around questions of safety,
questions of optimal treatment is another major use case OHDISI.